all right let's get into some of your
emails for the week if you want to send
an email and maybe have it featured in
the weekly email bag you can email info
davidpakman.com
please be aware i i can't believe i
still have to would make this
admonishment if you start emailing
multiple times a day and there are now
like 30 or 40 people doing it your
emails are being auto filtered into the
trash we just can't have this stuffed
email box
it's not what it's for we are not you
know some people are sending us just 30
news stories a day
um it's not an appropriate use of the
email box you you might as well stop
we're not seeing your emails but for
other people uh info davidpakman.com if
you're going to reasonably use that we
love hearing from you let's get right
into this week's email back bag a first
email is from jaybear who says why do
you avoid race and iq
are you afraid of the truth we've gotten
emails like this before
jay baer writes
you seem quite scared david of the truth
the link between race and iq is as clear
as day
stefan malinux and lauren southern have
discussed in length about this before
and they aren't racists
jews actually have higher iqs than
others and you probably realize this but
you can't say it don't be so afraid of
reporting the truth
listen to charles murray dr david duke
and stefan molyneux
every time i get one of these i always
have to do a two-part response
first of all
why are you so obsessed with this topic
with all of the things going on in the
world why would someone continually be
fixated on this topic but most
importantly it's not a subject that i've
voted avoided we have a long-form video
the truth about race and iq
go watch it and that's all i have to say
on the matter now the problem is people
see the video
and then they say well but david i don't
agree with your conclusions you need to
do another video
these folks won't be happy until i just
agree with them and that's a very
different uh
request that they're making we've talked
about it it's not an interesting topic
to me
we've said everything we want to say
about it and that's it
kyle wrote in kyle from south florida
about chris cuomo and says in chris
cuomo's defense
david i was listening to your take
yesterday on the situation regarding
chris cuomo's suspension from cnn i
agree with you for the most part him
using his connections to help his
brother during a scandal is totally
inappropriate and is absolutely a
violation of journalistic integrity
however i did not find it necessary to
warrant a suspension in cuomo's defense
he is the most watched hour of cnn as in
and is an influential voice on the left
why should he be suspended when
journalists on right-wing propaganda
networks resume business as usual making
wildly false claims and peddling
dangerous conspiracy conspiracy theories
as a progressive i'm getting tired of
holding ourselves to a certain moral
standard like journalistic integrity
while the right threw that out of the
window a long time ago
i'm not saying we should ever stoop to
their level but i am saying we may want
to reevaluate who and what we should be
condemning people for chris cuomo's
suspension is unnecessary
since this email it actually became a
firing i disagree with this you know
this is like when uh when keith
olbermann uh violated policy by making
some political donations when he was
working at msnbc and he was
was he suspended and then fired or just
fired
he was punished for it a whole bunch of
people said look at fox news the entire
network is politically biased people who
are participating in fundraisers for
candidates and doing all this stuff so
nothing should happen to keith olbermann
i i'd reject that once we say we don't
need to hold ourselves to sensible
standards because they aren't doing it
i think in some sense we become as bad
as them now i've said before
there are cases where we just need to
play the game for example gerrymandering
the way that the republican party has
gerrymandered manipulated congressional
districts to their advantage is
disgusting it shouldn't be allowed but
it is
and the left has no choice
but to do the same anytime they have the
opportunity
until such time that we have a different
way of drawing districts but you're
going to just keep losing if you don't
do that
but you work to change the rules
here what chris cuomo did is completely
inappropriate and the punishment has to
fit the actions not well what does or
what would fox news do so i think
kyle i appreciate the message we just
have a difference of opinion and that's
okay but i think that chris cuomo's
suspension uh was completely appropriate
um next email called fake news
you are correct in fact that trump
didn't invent the term fake news
actually it was one of hitler's favorite
terms of course he said lugen press i've
observed it on many trump supporters
probably neo-nazis i froze the first
time i heard it in our language in 2016
before the election i believe i saw his
ultimate intention then apparently
according to his first wife he read
hitler it's called my new order and that
alone is a little chilling so yeah our
so-called patriot mag crowd somehow
doesn't realize it's a fascist term used
by an evil man who proved his evil 100
times over yeah i mean listen
you're not wrong
even more recently the term fake news
within the united states had a
particular meaning
and it was like you know the the
national enquirer
hillary clinton giving birth to an alien
baby that's what we meant by fake news
donald trump has just completely changed
what it means into any reporting
critical
of me or things that i've done and said
and obviously that is a perversion of
what fake news uh has always has always
meant
um
next
is a tweet this was a tweet i got
i pointed out you know this this is
actually a bigger story
back when it was hillary clinton versus
donald trump in 2016.
there were some people on the left
saying
the supreme court i don't care about the
supreme court hillary and trump are the
same i don't care i'm not voting or i'm
writing someone in or whatever
donald trump got three supreme court
picks
um neil gorsuch brett kavanaugh and amy
coney barrett
and now as a result of that
roe v wade may be undone in the united
states we're not going to know until
june and so i tweeted if hillary had won
roe v wade wouldn't be on the chopping
block now a few people wrote back and
said things like well she said she would
be open to compromise on roe v wade
listen that's something she said she
wasn't going to put in three
anti-abortion supreme court justices
okay
a user on twitter wrote back and said if
hillary had won we'd be in two wars and
that is just such a boring tired
narrative
the the the killery stuff and we talked
about this monday in the context of joe
biden dramatically scaling back the
drone war
after
quite frankly decades of pushing this
neocon war mongering stuff trump came in
and said oh the iraq war was bad even
though he said it was good when he was
interviewed by howard stern way back
when
um and said i'm not gonna get us into
wars and hillary will
and many trumpists and republicans fell
for it hook line and sinker um hillary
clinton was not going to get us into two
wars
uh is it possible that she would have
engaged in some kind of military
conflicts airstrikes whatever absolutely
most presidents do trump did obama did
bush george
yes but this entire hillary was
bloodthirsty and looking to start wars
everywhere it simply was not based in in
any evidence and by the way they've been
saying the same thing about joe biden
we're not closer to any war
under joe biden if he starts one we will
talk about it believe me but uh it's
just a made up and concocted narrative
that a lot of people fell for and if you
actually ask them what evidence do you
have that hillary wanted to start two
wars see what happens see what they say
to you
uh okay next email
this one comes to us it's actually a
facebook message you are a piece of s
trump is the best president in my
lifetime 53 years trump had america
independent on oil not true unemployment
at all time low uh yes
unemployment was low that that's
absolutely true um and uh unemployment
is also uh really really low under joe
biden they're not giving joe biden any
credit for that
future jog outlook i guess they mean job
outlook highest ever and china economy
in shambles that's not true and of
course the tariffs on china were really
damaging to american companies and then
after getting an automatic response
saying that you know i can't respond to
these messages individually the same
person wrote back and said drop dead
liberal pukes
this is what we're up against guys
another facebook message
are you kidding me trump was the only
president that put our country first and
the american people first if you like
living in communist country move out
i am not a communist i'm not looking to
live in a communist country
i'm not looking for the united states to
become a communist country the continued
ignorance around what communism is
is plaguing us like a virus
for lack of a better term
bernard wrote in bernard writes
uh david i love your show bonhoeffer's
theory of stupidity
on youtube channel sprouts
goes into what is happening in america
right now and the danger of america
losing democracy
hope this helps
um yeah i actually recently read a very
good article on bonhoeffer's theory of
stupidity
and the main point of that is
stupidity is a more dangerous enemy of
the good than evil and there's a number
of different ways in which you can make
that case i am very sympathetic to that
idea
and a part of what makes stupidity a
more dangerous enemy than evil
is that
stupidity
lends itself to manipulation in a very
particular way
that as we saw
quite frankly under trump
lends itself to getting people to
believe and support absurd things not
because they actually like them
but because they don't even understand
them they've been tricked they've been
bamboozled and i think
there's a really good if you search
google for bonhoeffer's theory of
stupidity there's a medium article that
explains it in some pretty good detail
that's worth reading
uh john wrote in and says where did
trump's oratory skills come from david
regardless of your or my feelings on his
character or policies
you have to admit that trump is a
skilled public speaker although he has
his malfunction malfunctions united
chesh and finding the oranges to name a
few he never ums or errs and can easily
hold the crowd's attention for an
extended time my question is where did
these skills come from i don't think he
had any formal training or would have a
chance to exercise them locked up in
that tower of his what do you think yeah
you know i mean here's the thing john in
a sense you're right
john uh trump was able early on to
generate interest
his speeches were were kind of wacky and
entertaining in a sense his press
briefings were certainly more lively
than those that joe biden has done but
at the same time a lot of times trump's
rally crowds were completely bored
remember for a while when trump would
come out with papers with polling on
them and he would start reading polls
and the crowd was totally checked out
recently he's done like hour and a half
hour 45 minute rallies a few months ago
and the crowd is totally tuned out so i
do agree that trump has
something that makes him entertaining to
some in a superficial way but he also
often loses the crowd in a very
immediate and kind of jarring way so i i
don't know
um
even myself
while as you say i don't like the guy's
policy positions or anything else i did
find myself entertained by some of his
events
but recently the endless sort of like
castro type rallies where he's just
going on and on and on about nothing
it's not really entertaining and a lot
of people start walking out so i think
it's a mix
and
trump fundamentally is an entertainer so
it shouldn't shock us that he has some
tools to entertain on a superficial
level and obviously you and i agree for
the country it's not a good thing at all
we have a great bonus show for you today
sign up at joinpakman.com you'll get
instant access to the bonus show as well
as our commercial free audio feeds and
commercial free video feeds for members
only sign up at joinpakman.com you can
use the coupon code better21 to get a
discount